across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves when survival's the goal it's
into the spider hole
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers
whoever was there has left or they've
got a problem who have devised extensive
plans this is redneck faraday cage you
know i love you and this is because i
want to protect you nathan gone to great
lengths
and made huge personal sacrifices to
ensure their very survival you just got
to keep telling yourself to keep going
the experts will assess their extreme
preps and decide if they have what it
takes to face armageddon
and to survive
appetizing
there it is folks this is doomsday
preppers
[Music]
behind the closed doors of this cookie
cutter home there's a closely guarded
family secret
to their neighbors former construction
specialist barry his girlfriend pink and
his son cole are just another regular
family living on a suburban block
unfortunate because
no one in this neighborhood
even knows this is here
some people call it extreme i don't
really this is going down below right
yeah that goes down below it's kind of
like camping except
we're less than 10 feet from our house
carefully concealed underneath barry's
garage floor is a concrete pod that he
calls an urban foxhole
a place to survive the end of the world
this urban foxhold this is much more
than a safe room you can survive almost
any kind of disaster in this barry's
foxhole is water fire and chemical
resistant the eight by eight by eight
living space is constructed from
concrete and formed into the strongest
geometric shape in the world a sphere
in the beginning stages of inventing
this pod barry and i used to sit in the
garage even
to two three o'clock in the morning and
we used to take chalk and draw on the
garage floor the family built the
foxhole in complete secret digging out
100 cubic yards of dirt by hand then
disposing of it in a dump trailer
without ever opening the garage door
it'd be bad if uh
we're sitting here doing this and
someone with the garage door opener
pulls up and opens the crash door on us
and reveals this i was so passionate
about it because i knew they understand
the need of it barry first had the idea
for the urban foxhole four years ago
when along with millions of other
americans he watched his savings
disappear in the 2008 economic crash
i lost everything you know i was a week
from retirement like so many other
people around the country you know who
have no retirement anymore really makes
you stop and think who's going to take
care of your
family if uh
you know if you can't from that point
forward barry decided that instead of
building back his 401k
he would start prepping
we'll leave here but we'll inventory it
i have the list right there i have five
children my oldest boy jerry is 29
he's been key to developing this with me
my other kids are kind of uh
dad you're sort of nuts
but uh i'm not jerry yeah can you look
in the storage space and make sure
i put some towels in there you got it
some people may say that we're obsessed
with prepping but i'd rather be safe and
called obsessed than be
naive and not being able to protect the
people i care about and we have a little
extra because inevitably someone's going
to show up we have to take care of
barry and pink have amassed enough food
and water for five people to survive in
the foxhole without going outside for 60
days
it has bacon
you'll like that i get all the bacon a
time period they see as critical for
their worst case scenario
i think the world's never been more
dangerous i think that's why prepping is
so important these days
i think one of the most likely
catastrophes is a
social economic collapse that comes from
an emp device that goes off
an emp or electromagnetic pulse attack
can be caused by a nuclear blast
detonated high in the atmosphere above
the united states
the electrical energy surge released
from such a detonation has the potential
power to take out any electronic device
in its path
there's a lot of people that don't like
us an emp device is the best way to
knock the big bully giant down and we'll
be back into the
18th century virtually overnight
a recent government report suggests that
because an emp attack could bring down
the electrical grid it is a scenario
that could threaten multiple systems of
infrastructure
including food
water
emergency services
gas
telecommunications and finance
if the catastrophe goes on long enough
you are going to see people just turn
against each other we plan on staying
right here protecting our stores not
letting anybody know we have it as far
as anyone's concerned we'll be suffering
just like them
but to bunker down without electricity
barry and pink have to think of some
doomsday practicalities
like toilets
all of america's 19 500 sewage plants
rely on electrical pumps so if an emp
device goes off we're not going to have
any electricity which means no city
water no sewage nothing's going to run
and we have to be prepared to store our
own waste this is our toilet for the
urban foxhole this is all the sanitary
when it drops down in here that actually
closes back it seals it once the
pressure goes down and it passes by here
it seals it off oh i see i see so it
didn't take much weight to move that no
so there's like 780 of these that
actually
coil up when you're all done with it
this bag right here you can take it out
and cut it off and it's gonna look like
poop sausage you don't have to handle
your waste
the key to it is uh
storing your
liquids and solids separately if the
liquids and the solids are mixed
together
it'll ferment much quicker after a
couple days the bag would expand and
want to pop
that would be bad i'd rather use this in
a ziploc bag i am a girl that would be a
little awkward barry and pink have spent
over seventy thousand dollars preparing
for the worst but as of yet they have
not had a full dry run of foxhole living
so this weekend he is putting himself
and his family to the test let's run a
drill um
as if there was an emp device and social
chaos is going on we've never stayed a
full night in the urban foxhole so
60 days is going to be a real trial we
need to get a feel for what it's going
to be like i spent seven years in the
military there's just no substitute for
training
when people know what to do it just
moves so much cleaner and faster i'll
stand watch tonight okay you'll take the
outside watch with the radio we'll have
a watch stander in the main room of the
house as if we were watching out for the
roving bands of neighbors looking for
something to eat
while pink stan's watch cole jerry and
barry will cook eat and live in the
foxhole for one night
do you remember what you're supposed to
do yeah go to the laundry room shut the
door go into the garage
and then walk it from the outside and
then head into the pod cole is quite a
character i still like to say his tent
he reminds me he's 11.
um he is the biggest joy why is that
important you remember
yeah because if somebody's chasing you
they don't have the key it'll take them
a while to get through there that's
right good job okay this is our
perimeter alarm i'm going to set it and
when it's activated
that'll begin our drill
knowing that in a real emergency an
intruder could be chasing them barry
jerry and cole need to get into the
foxhole as quickly as possible
[Music]
check are you in the pod insecure
okay we need to make sure that we have
the kitchen stuff what we need to cook a
meal tonight this place is awesome
i guess
is it still gonna be awesome eight hours
from now
no
without a dedicated air supply the
foxhole would run out of oxygen in just
six hours so in case an emp does take
down the grid barry is teaching cole how
to use his hand crank air system
you're gonna mount this right on top
right there okay and then you're just
gonna use the handle and pull up and
down and up and down got it calculated
out to where every 10 hours a grown man
needs 80 cubic feet
of air space to breathe
barry has planned out each detail of
foxhole living with military precision
you get any meatballs that's what we're
having okay i would take anything over
dad having chili tonight
we would need to see how many calories
are in this divide this by three
to survive even when resting each person
must eat at least 1200 calories a day
for the end of the world this is a
thanksgiving meal right here you could
be eating bugs outside
give it a try
hmm
how many calories is it 216. 2016
there's three of us right
all right you gonna leave a little for
the other survivors
i doubt it
right now cool
what it comes down to is surviving the
other people that are in there and how
much they drive you crazy to spend 60
days down here i'll be tortured 500 to
get on the board
keeping guard at night
is scary
because you don't know what you're
expecting
so there are people going to be breaking
into our house is there going to be
tanks going down the road you have no
idea
but it's gratifying in the same way
because you're the first one to tell the
people that you love to stay in stay
safe and lock up and don't come out
[Music]
living for 60 days with less than 13
square feet per person is a challenge
even for a season prepper but where
barry's post-apocalyptic plan gets
really interesting is after 60 days
when their stores run out it's either
bug out
or die
to survive an electromagnetic pulse that
could take down much of america's
electrical grid barry has built a secret
concrete pod underneath his garage floor
called the urban foxhole coast is clear
from the top are you guys up and ready
proud you were ready
last night he and his kids jerry and
cole did their first emergency bug in
drill spending an entire night under the
hatch while barry's girlfriend pink
stood guard above rise and shine it's
morning time good morning
good morning how did it
go for you guys let's roll out it went
great but barry's weekend of drills is
not over he's now eager to test out
stage two of his doomsday plan well
we're prepared to uh
stay right here in the urban foxhole and
use this for 60 days my worst case
scenario is if it lasts more than 60
days
and things just don't seem safe we will
have to leave while some disasters have
been shown to bring people together
experts are concerned that an emp could
be an exception to the rule because key
repairs to the electrical grid could
take from six months to a year leaving
millions of people without heat water
and transport so when the going gets
rough barry wants to be ready to bug out
of danger we're going to start on our
first leg up here
we're going to get to the sailboat which
is here if it goes past 60 days we'll
we'll make our way to sea
because i think you stand a much better
chance surviving at sea than you do on
land
tonight barry and his family will run a
practice bug out to puget sound where he
has a sailboat moored
okay okay all right that's what we'll do
in preparation barry and his son jerry
are burying supplies along their route
so that cedar tree would be a good mark
for us this will be our first stop to
the sailboat here
and let's just make sure that no one's
coming up the trail before we leave the
trail okay this is gonna be our very
first geostash geostashes are
strategically hidden containers of food
and water that will allow the family to
bug out without being weighed down by
heavy packs
so our path between the urban fox hall
and the sailboat is marked with
containers full of
food water and energy drinks
barry and jerry will use a gps device to
map the coordinates of their stash but
in case the satellites fail them they
also record distinctive visual markers
on our gps we're coming into the pitch
dark and this might be really
hard to see
so wait a minute
let's keep going all right let's bury
this bag away
let's get some cover on it
make it look like nobody was here i'm
good with that that looks good okay
watch those thorns on the way out
[Music]
because an emp could render computer
chips and most vehicles useless the
family plan to travel the 15 miles to
their boat on foot it'll be like a real
video game adventure only in real life
except for all the monster killing and
stuff
60 days after an emp attack the 17 500
people living in barry's suburb won't
have had electricity or running water
for two months so barry wants to prepare
for a highly dangerous and potentially
volatile environment the safest way to
ever move when you're in danger is to
move it dark
that's why special forces operate at
night that's why the military operates
at night the cover of darkness can be
your best friend let's cut across this
way the family travels in single file
because it allows them to naturally
camouflage themselves in darkness they
appear as one person from the front and
rear okay i was off to the right keep
going cole i know you're tired but you
just got to keep going all right
two hours into the hike they are close
to their first geostash point i don't
know what's around here
well we're looking for a cedar tree
oh i heard it i heard it great this is
the spot we got it
right this is like gold
all right we should have put your knife
away
all right oh my goodness
yeah make sure you hydrate because um
it's gonna be a long long trip
how are you doing cool
good good
we gotta hurry so try to get that down
need the container here just put them
aside
the family still has hours of hiking
ahead of them but once they reach the
ocean how long will they be able to
survive on the open sea
and let's cut across to prepare for an
emp attack that could take out the
electrical grid and plunge society into
chaos barry knowles and his family are
testing out an overnight bug out to
their sailboat
we'll be able to kind of creep silently
we'll be dressed in dark clothing we're
not going to be easily noticeable after
15 miles of hiking and just as dawn
breaks they reach the boat yard from
here they will head to the nearest
uninhabited island and set up a
temporary camp
i have a couple of islands that are
completely uninhabited in the north
puget sound and will immediately set
sail for one of those
[Music]
this is our new home
now until we find a safer place to be
this is this is where we're going to be
this is much better than being in a town
with two million people trying to avoid
other people who are desperate this
feels good to me hey cole what are you
thinking catch a fish what are you gonna
do with it eat it eat it
that sounds good
with an unlimited supply of seafood and
a boat stocked with 2 000 pounds of
supplies barry and pink's biggest
challenge in the ocean is not food but
water
so why can't we drink salt water do you
remember i don't remember don't remember
it makes us dehydrate
yes salt makes your brain swell
makes you uh hallucinate drinking
seawater in large quantities would
result in kidney failure and eventually
death so in the middle of the ocean a
good filtration system is key to
survival so i learned how to do this in
the military and i used to evaporate
water for ships
so we've got that so we've got the salt
water from the ocean in here
and we're heating it steam vapor's
coming off of it it's coming into these
condensation tubes right here
re-cooling back in the water and here
comes a little bit right now
there see a little bit of the time here
it's gonna taste it's hot
just take a little tiny sip all right
oh right it's okay is it good
it works all right that's how we'll make
our fresh water cool until we find some
other source
i'm very patriotic so it'd be a very
difficult thing for me to sail away from
the united states i would do so to save
my family but it would be heartbreaking
to know that cole he can be safe and he
can grow up and he can have a life
because now he's protected in case a
disaster happens
it is the most amazing heartfelt
thing i could probably think of
[Music]
the experts practical preppers believe
your 60-day food and water supplies are
adequate preparations for a short-term
bug-in
i agree that was our plan
to survive the initial attack however
your shelter may be inadequate for
long-term survival the size of it does
not allow you to store huge amounts of
prepping supplies and your items left in
the house are unsecured and easily
looted i agree with that assessment it
wasn't designed for long term also your
boat may be damaged or stolen or not
serviceable creating a potential
disaster in your bug-out plan
it's always a chance we have to take
will the boat still be there because
maybe people have torn it apart to burn
it for fuel
1700 miles away from barry in the deep
midwest
steve pace is a retired army sergeant
who served his country for three decades
now he's spending his golden years with
his wife martha in the small farming
community of campbell missouri
population
2165. the people that are in this
community are honest they're hard
workers we know everybody we keep an eye
on each other's places we work together
as a community
friendly neighbors are not the only
reason steve moved to campbell a few
years ago
he relocated specifically to prepare for
a high altitude nuclear explosion that
would cause the catastrophic failure of
our nation's power grid there's no doubt
about it the biggest threat to our
civilization is the loss of the
electrical grid
i personally believe that either north
korea
china
possibly iran will attempt to shut down
the grid by a nuclear delivered
electromagnetic pulse over central
united states
an emp would destroy electronic devices
including transformers which are a
central component to the country's
fragile power infrastructure
all the transformers will be going off
like popcorn popping when it happens
you'll see a bright light in the sky
and then i'll throw the keys out of your
pocket because they'll be burning your
leg then
it's gone but the damage is done we're
looking at one to two years without
power
steve knows that if an emp occurred
communication devices would be damaged
immediately his first plan is to protect
his crank radio and walkie-talkies in a
faraday cage so we can broadcast
survival advice to his fellow campbell
residents
and 99 percent of the people don't even
know what a fair day cage is let alone
know to go put their radio in there a
faraday cage is a metal container that
acts as a shield against electromagnetic
waves by forcing the electrical current
around the structure
leave the rest down it is common for
preppers to spend hundreds of dollars on
faraday cages but steve's is built
from a garbage can
this is redneck faraday cage
[Music]
you don't need a lot of expensive gear
to be a prepper the more you spend on a
fair day cage the less it'll probably
work steve and martha know exactly how
to assemble a faraday cage but they have
never before tested its effectiveness
i'm fixing to test this faraday cage
tony i'm going to test this faraday cage
you want to come watch i'll come watch
and you can tell me what what's fair day
cage
and his brother tony are applying the
electrical current of a 12-volt truck
battery to the trash can which contains
his crank radio and walkie-talkies
if and properly connected an automobile
battery can explode hold this in
is there any danger of the battery doing
anything we will step back
got a negative clamp to it
i just saw it i can hear it it's popping
we're gonna give it about 10 seconds
okay an emp wouldn't last no longer than
that i mean it's more like a
you know i mean that's the way it
happens and if it works okay
the electronics come out and they work
they should okay yeah open it up see
what's going on
nothing blew up in there nope they're
running too i can hear them check one
toe check one two check one two check
one two
emp is over
lights are out night night
nothing steve does is going to surprise
me i'm used to him having a box of gas
masks in the corner i've seen his
chemical suits
if a nuclear weapon were detonated in
the earth's atmosphere steve believes
that the fallout from the explosion
would descend to the ground he knows
radioactivity is invisible so he's
training himself in how to use a geiger
counter
the only way i'm going to know that
there's any radiation around is the
geiger counter you have to trust the
geiger counter
the effects of high exposure become
visible quickly
one absorbed dose of radiation is called
a rad if you're standing in one rad per
hour radiation 50 hours of that will
kill you
steve that is really an interesting
looking garb you have on
georgina i'm checking for i'm checking
for radiation
if steve detected unsafe levels of
radiation after an emp he plans to
transmit this information to the
campbell community i hope the ham radio
at the police station still works so we
can notify that we have radiation here
if it's very high we have to leave
because you can't stay
that's simple do we have any no you're
safe we have no radiation today good
good
i'm so thankful you look out for me
you're a good neighbor we like to look
out for everybody his mind is always
working always and coming up with
solutions just in case he looks ahead
and plans ahead
and that's what i like about my neighbor
steve
i have an internal
need
to to be responsible for my environment
is that responsibility or is it just
common human decency i don't know but
i've got a heavy dose of it
a few years ago when i moved here
people knew i was a prepper because i
would tell them i'm sure they considered
me chicken little for a while but they
got a wake-up call two years ago in 2009
campbell had a severe ice storm snapping
power poles and destroying transmission
lines
125 000 residents in the region lost
electricity some for up to 30 days
now the people when they see me on the
streets they say hey i got me some
oil lamps i've got me some batteries and
flashlights i'm contagious or something
everybody around me is turning into
preppers
steve wants his prepping message to
spread beyond friends and neighbors he
would like the entire community to
prepare for an emp
so he's heading right to the top of
campbell's chain of command
steve pace believes that an
electromagnetic pulse will soon destroy
the nation's power grid and is
determined to persuade those in charge
of his small missouri town to prepare
for the worst i've talked to the mayor
and
the representative from missouri state
law enforcement
they're going to meet me at city hall
we're going to
discuss the emp this town's been without
power that that's the way we need to do
it too
steve's friend and local state trooper
dennis is joining him in his first
face-to-face meeting with the mayor
hello is mayor here
how you doing
how are you long time no see good scene
you ready for a little uh get together
the meeting yes yes
an electromagnetic pulse is going to
knock out the grid no doubt about it
what i would like to discuss what can we
do to prepare for long-term outage
as compared to the trial run we had two
years ago which we did quite well we had
water and sewer and that made all the
difference in the world water supply
systems are dependent on electricity
during the ice storm campbell was able
to maintain these vital public works
because they had purchased backup
generators that run on diesel fuel
we not only did that for the water and
the sewer but we also have one for the
police station right the community
building and the city hall long-term emp
we're looking at six months to a year
because of all the transformers blown
government officials have found over 300
transformers in the country's power grid
that could be permanently damaged in a
severe emp and leave 40 of americans
without electricity indefinitely
if this thing is a six month to a year
process
to be realistic
i think it would be the biggest mess
that you could ever imagine i don't
think any community no matter how big
could handle the situation i don't know
if you can prepare for that i really
don't i mean as a rule
goodwill is short-lived yes i mean as a
rule because you're going to have areas
and they're going to protect what they
have
with everything they have to keep it
it's as simple as that steve fears that
masses of people from the nearby
powerless cities will invade campbell in
search of food and water
the groups gains that's coming out of
the cities
they're offensive people they're looking
to take our stuff our assets i don't
think there's enough of us
to stop that from happening at all
steve knows that campbell's small police
force is not big enough to control
marauders so he plans to help them
protect and serve
you don't go into combat without water
beans and bullets
whoever was there has left or they've
got a problem
not even radiation will stop him from
safeguarding his community
just because you're in a contaminated
area doesn't mean somebody's not wanting
your stuff steve recently began target
practice wearing an israeli civilian gas
mask about an inch high although it is
designed with large eye openings and he
has 30 years of marksmanship skills
acquiring a target is difficult
i'll clear the turret and lose it
well i'm not such a good shot with that
mask on am i
i'm thinking i'm just going to have to
have more practice i'm a little
surprised how
difficult it was if the assault on
campbell gets serious steve has also
been prepping an emp proof getaway
vehicle
[Music]
i've got a four-wheel bike i put a motor
on it because an emp would disable all
modern vehicles steve chose a commercial
quadricycle that cannot only carry
multiple people
but also hundreds of pounds of supplies
does look a little silly
but i don't want to walk 20 miles to get
rice when i can ride 20 miles the one
horsepower motor has a mechanical
ignition system that would withstand an
emp surge and it runs on alternative
energy sources it'll run on vodka
whiskey anything
over 100 proof it'll run on
it really is too
today steve is assessing the motor's
condition to make sure it is operating
at peak performance
how you doing he has enlisted the help
of dennis to track his speed i need to
be able to go faster and somebody can
run i'm shooting for top speed that's
all i know i hope it's 20. there you go
you'd be surprised what one horse will
do
[Music]
[Applause]
and there he goes
speed should show up in this window
right here
oh there you go
what what was the top speed you saw
got you one time at 12 mile an hour
the average person can run 10 miles an
hour making steve's bike just fast
enough to dodge potential assaults yeah
you know when he's trying to outrun a
horde of people
you know there might be that jackrabbit
in there that's going to snatch him up
before he can get away to maintain
waterworks in an emergency steve knows
that campbell has 5 000 gallons of
diesel fuel to operate their backup
generators
and steve has an 80d reserve of water
for him and martha but if these supplies
ran out he has a last resort plan it
looks like i was drinking beer last
night he's ahead on that
steve pace is willing to go to any
length to prepare for an emp attack and
a resulting grid down situation and if
his small town's water pump stayed down
indefinitely he knows he may need to
resort to desperate measures
it looks like i was drinking beer last
night he's a head on that
there it is folks
steve and martha would filter their own
urine using a portable charcoal water
filter
the charcoal is porous and catches
impurities as the liquid passes through
the filter which steve hopes will make
his urine safe to drink it's still got a
slight yellow tint to it that's a tinge
that's a far cry from what it was when
it came out as a sample what land yes
drinking the unfiltered urine of a
healthy person would keep someone alive
for a maximum of two days
i claim it's not urine now
now it is a
clear
almost clear clean purified
liquid water i'm amazed
tastes like chlorinated water
really that's simple
taste it just put it on your lips
if this was your last resort you're
going to do it to survive here's cheers
to last resort
the main reason i am a prepper
is for family
uh
community
freedom
uh
injustice preparing will ease your mind
instead of producing fear
steve the experts practical preppers
believe you have a wide range of
innovative skills that will benefit you
after a nuclear emp attack however you
need to develop a backup water plan such
as a rain catchment system so you are
sufficiently covered
i do have a water catchment system but
it's not deployed also you need to plan
for the eventuality that in dire
circumstances your community could fall
apart i know the people in this
community and 90 percent of them are
going to stand arm in arm with me we
have to believe that we can overpower
the 10 percent that may want to take
over so to speak
since national geographic was here the
city of campbell is in the process of
purchasing
15 transformers we'll have them on hand
ready to go
one second post event if we need to
while there are many prominent political
figures concerned about the possibility
of an electromagnetic pulse crippling
the united states infrastructure most
experts believe that such an attack is
unlikely
[Music]
the small town of fort mills south
carolina
an ordinary suburban street
laura kunzi goes through normal morning
rituals
proper shoes
[Music]
the perfect matching necklace
[Music]
preparing a healthy breakfast for her
husband brian and son nathan
but for laura all is not right she
worries that something deadly is in the
air
i'm preparing for an avian flu pandemic
avian flu or h5n1 is a strain of the
influenza virus that is highly
contagious in bird populations around
the world
humans usually contract avian flu
through direct contact with birds
but in 2006 avian flu was passed between
humans in a village in indonesia
for laura this was a game changer
pandemics are the only disaster without
boundaries it's not something that you
can escape
if one human is sick they can carry that
virus across the world within hours
and every person they come in contact
with has the potential to also carry
that virus
laura spends every day preparing for an
avian flu outbreak that would claim
millions of lives
i think i have a greater awareness of
the potential
of disasters including pandemics just
because of my desire to make sure that
my family is protected
so just like the centers for disease
control in atlanta laura pays extremely
close attention to any outbreak of avian
flu around the world
i research it on a daily basis i have
apps available on my ipad i've got an
rss feed that gives me the latest
information on the avian flu
there are small pockets of infection it
is not yet mutated to a point where it
can go from human to human rapidly but
she's not only tracking infection risks
from abroad
laura keeps a close watch on what
happens in fort mills
one unfortunate change she's noticed is
the increase in the local bird
population this is the place where it
could all begin with one sick bird
it could happen today
open bodies of water and wild water fowl
are considered natural hot zones for the
avian flu virus infected birds may not
show signs of infection it only takes
one mutation for the virus to pass from
bird to human the geese population in
this area specifically has probably
tripled since 2006 and
it's
more of a problem now with their
droppings
laura doesn't just worry about the avian
flu she's actively preparing her
community to fight it bye
see you later
we talk with people who say oh i'm not
prepared at all what would i do if they
can't go down to the store and buy
food that day or whatever it might be
they're they're done through her small
business she caters to the needs of
local preppers with everything from bug
out bags to face masks to water filters
i was in the coast guard for eight years
and it really helped me in being ready
at all times and understanding really
what that means i love discussing goals
with my customers and helping them with
a solution that's right for their family
so
excuse me could you help me with this
absolutely this is the filter for virus
without chemical
and the great thing about that is that
during a pandemic you're going to want
something like this to filter out
viruses so you can just take dirty water
out of a mud hole or something and put
it through there and it comes out good
absolutely would you like to test it out
yeah yeah that'd be great
preparing for a pandemic it goes beyond
a mask
our infrastructure could break down
it is estimated that 1.9 million people
would die during an avian flu pandemic
people don't just at the end of that
pandemic get up from their sick bed and
walk out some of them may not ever
return to their jobs
utilities like water treatment plants
could lose large numbers of personnel
leading to acute shortages and
services having a reliable system for
water purification is critical because
the body is easily dehydrated during an
influenza infection
watch where you're stepping there's a
lot of droppings everywhere
see there are all those geese around
here
birds can transmit avian flu through
their bodily fluids and feces where the
virus can survive for up to 100 days
any contact can make a person vulnerable
to infection
the way that this filter works is by
gravity so the higher the height we're
going to get the greater the flow that
we're going to get for the water
laura's filter uses a process similar to
kidney dialysis to pull out bacteria and
viruses among other contaminants salud
one of the most important sources of
that your family is going to need is
water so that's going to be really
important that your family's not
drinking contaminated water
laura believes she will be the last line
of defense between her family and the
avian flu but will her family survive
her preps
i'm freezing why do we have to do this
again disaster doesn't wait for warm
weather
laura kunzi believes it's only a matter
of time before an avian flu pandemic
sweeps the globe
with a pandemic there's a potential of
that happening at any moment
she's prepared to provide her own water
supply in the absence of utilities and
laura has a serious plan to ensure her
home will remain a safe place
in the event of a pandemic our home if
we don't plan properly could be a prison
but if we plan properly and have the
right supplies
it's going to be a fortress
today laura has enlisted the help of a
nurse to lend her expertise in building
effective and thorough decontamination
measures
hi i'm marianne hi marianne nice to meet
you so we need to set up a
decontamination site okay how do we get
started we need a hose
we need a kiddie pool some stakes
a shower curtain
with deadly contagion potentially
wafting through the air each home should
have its own decontamination site near
entryways to stop germs from getting
inside
we always wear heels with our
decontamination suit a disposable hazmat
suit can limit laura's exposure to the
avian flu virus
and because suits like this one are made
from lightweight plastic they are an
affordable proper resource making them
easy to stockpile
pandemic has happened you two have been
exposed i'm not no i'm not exposed you
built this decontamination shower
because you're not going back in that
house with those germs i'm dad you're in
sorry buddy
overruled
in the real event you take everything
off
h5n1 virus can be carried from one area
to another on clothing and shoes
especially the soles as one can
unknowingly step on a contaminated
surface
exposed garments should be
decontaminated or destroyed i'm freezing
why do we have to do this again disaster
doesn't wait for warm weather take this
that's antibacterial soap you use that
on the outside only not in the house
wash your hair with it
influenza viruses are relatively weak
outside a host's body thoroughly
scrubbing with the common soap is
sufficient to kill any influenza virus
present on skin and hair
still wondering why my mom's not in here
uh she tries to get me to play guinea
pig but normally i get out of it one way
or another i don't know why i'm not
quite so lucky this time
the next step after decontamination is
to change into clean clothing and foot
protection to avoid further spread of
the virus
can i go inside no you can but the
drill's not over there's one more step
the quarantine room
the third and final step would be to
create a quarantine room to isolate
suspected carriers
today the united states has 20
quarantine stations and entry points
around the country
and now laura is building the 21st
station
in her home if you were really exposed
you'd have to be in quarantine for two
weeks so i don't have to go to school
for two weeks unfortunately you're gonna
have to go to school this is just a
drill
avian flu symptoms can take anywhere
from three to fourteen days to manifest
given the highly contagious nature of
the virus in a pandemic scenario it is
important to keep suspected carriers
isolated during that time you're going
to see
only your mom who's a designated
caretaker you will not be seeing your
dad so i have to just sit in here by
myself and do nothing
i want to make sure there's no air
coming in or out of the room
we're going to do the plastic over the
doors
to create a physical barrier between the
virus and the rest of the family laura
can hang any type of plastic sheeting
from drop cloths to shower curtains
we're doing two barriers
this helps to isolate the virus even
more than just one to keep it out by
hanging a double barrier laura is
building a makeshift contamination
control room
so it's just an extra layer of
protection exactly
have a good night
night love you
too
she will leave her contaminated clothing
in the clean room before exiting
nathan's quarantine room to limit the
spread of the virus throughout the house
coming back right
you have to stay here all night
laura the experts practical preppers
think you need to have stored at least
six months of water for drinking hygiene
and cooking i feel like the filter
solution that we have in place right now
is sufficient for my family's needs
also you may want to rethink your
footwear in the event of a real
emergency
i may be wearing my heels but if i have
to i'll just take out my chainsaw blade
and cut them off and
be on my way
the world health organization says that
influenza pandemics can cause severe
social economic and political stress but
while historically they have continued
to occur their appearance and severity
is unpredictable
[Music]
you